Comcast leading I mean maybe instead of
offing fools at the beginning of this
movie this kid's dad should be teaching
her about within sentence capitalization
not to mention the size disparity
between the letters does that stand for
number one dad
no one's dad anyone's dad if you're
going to do the vanity plate at least
make it obvious although I actually do
hope it stands for anyone's dad because
that kind would have some stories
apparently she's allergic to bullets
[Music]
plastered and furious no kyo drift
listening to w exp exposition radio all
exposition all the time
I'm not saying Jeff Victoria and Lily
should all be dead after that crash but
I am saying they shouldn't be alive I
wonder if the hell beaches are home if
not maybe we know next door to the Gary
mods or maybe down the street to the
times new roman' I mean they go near
this house it's obvious from this poor
fox that the White Witch is around here
somewhere why two kids in horror movies
react with nonchalance to the
supernatural if this little girl
actually saw a woman levitating wouldn't
she have enough life experience to freak
them out a bit Jeff shot and killed his
wife
he wasn't forgetting to get milk on the
way home because he was too busy banging
his secretary I think we've sailed past
the sometimes we mess things up staged
it always sucks to get typecast but to
be the guy whose thing is trying to kill
kids that's a whole different level of
suck yeah these pictures are creepy and
unsettling but where are the kids
getting all the crayons to draw them
also over two full minutes of horror
child fridge art titles before were
movie finally gets back to movie his
characters first two scenes involve a
hallelujah at a negative pregnancy test
and making fun of her boyfriends desire
to find his brother and nieces who've
been missing for five years Annabelle is
making a hard run at worst leading
character in film history it's okay with
me cheaper than therapy Jessica Chastain
and Nikolaj coster-waldau are using the
scene to see once and for all who can be
hotter while play
slightly scaled up character I love the
idea of a Jessica Chastain kiss as much
as the next person
but not one filled with Raisin Bran so
after five years of snowfall rain and
whatever other natural occurrences have
happened in and around this car it's
still in the exact same place it was and
in pretty much the exact same condition
and it was never found by some random
hikers reported and tied back to Jeff's
disappearance and the first of this
movies million moth March flutters bond
why moths because the word mother begins
with M oth I'd almost take a sin off for
that bit of cleverness if I actually
thought it was intentional it's Jerry
pitch that whole pile is cherry pits
from the last five years there are about
25,000 cherry pits in a gallon and that
pile is at least 25 gallons that's at
least six hundred twenty-five thousand
bits are roughly three hundred and forty
two cherries per day for a full five
years even setting aside the nutritional
implications they seem to have exceeded
max cherry also why are they all piled
up here in this one place that the girls
decide to dispose of them in as creepy
away as possible and this is the worst
movie band I've seen since sexual
chocolate dr. Gerald Dreyfuss and you
must yet about discount Tony Shalhoub
the girls have lost the capacity to
communicate but luckily they retained
their ability to properly jumpscared
we're very fortunate that Victoria was
old enough to retain much of her
vocabulary
big time while keeping her basic
vocabulary all these years - Victoria
also developed superhuman speed they
called her mama roll mamas and enough
plays in a band you draw pictures for a
living dr. Gerald Dreyfuss MD for when
you want a heaping helping of insulting
douchebaggery with your mediocre medical
advice rent-free he moved in a house you
got the cows this is a joke right
even though she's a pedestrian bassist
and a terrible mother figure Annabelle
shows raw talent at cinemasins
right now they need a little space this
is said with a straight face in front of
a media throne go on Victoria Gees for a
character that's ultimately a decent do
they sure do make the doctor out to be
super creepy
mrs. sensitivity you are in a rock band
and therefore mandated to be an asshole
it's in the Charter and everything
geez Lucas Denham much you're a bearded
artist that's dating a tatted-up
musician we get it you're a hipster
considering they just moved out of a
small apartment Lucas and Annabelle
having a lot of fun boxes but you told
me that there were no mental hospitals
in the area Saint Gertrude shut down in
1878 Louise buried the lead for no good
reason it's as if she knows she's in a
movie and has to fit the narrative to
make it more suspenseful and twisty
movie posing
trickier but once again we have a
ghostly presence who would rather around
for a while instead of dispatching with
Lucas and Annabel Tim how did Lily know
how to time the lights coming out with
her a sent up on top of the counter to
scare Annabel this is the problem with
overly atmospheric horror films there's
no real reason for him to be reacting to
this moth like it's some sort of strange
confusing phenomenon he hasn't even seen
anything supernatural yet I swear to God
80 percent of this movie is buildups to
jump scares and 36 percent of it is
Jessica Chastain complaining about
watching the kids was mama intentionally
trying to make this look like an
accident instead of killing Lucas
outright like has she been watching that
48 hours mystery show that tells you how
to get away with criminal I guess this
means we're not gonna have sex tonight
also I believe the first step in
applying first aid to someone who has
taken a hard fall there's to shake their
head and scream their name at them it's
very likely in this coma stammering in
fact it's so temporary that it'll end up
sinking perfectly with the plot to do
don't you lose custody and Lucas will be
lucky if he sees his nieces every second
Thanksgiving how is this even an option
Annabelle has zero custody rights to the
shining girls yet Jean should get them
immediately process they made that I
mean this creepy doll that appears to
have some animal bones four legs and
actual teeth in its face and is also
wrapped an old wire and vine that could
scratch them while they sleep yeah we
totally let them keep that because
parenting is hard you know no one will
be seated during the dr. Dreyfus reviews
his interview videos session this is
Kristian forge public records I found
something that you will want to see nice
but what is this comment what is the
scene what the hell is this movie
nothing is Victoria talking about what's
in the closet or what actually happens
in this movie Victoria is showing signs
of a disassociative personality disorder
not only is this hilariously
mispronounced and the disorder doesn't
exist a movie for even introducing this
stupid cliche am i safe what the crazy
annual can you break this asshole is so
heavily invested into these girls that
he gave Jamie and Miss Sloan a fucking
house but he immediately dismisses
Victoria as crazy good thing exactly
what we are looking for is right here at
eye level instead of you know up here a
ghost is an emotion bent out of shape
condemned to repeat itself until it
writes the wrong that was done kind of
like how Hollywood chooses movies then
also luckily for Dreyfuss Louise
along with being records clerk is also a
ghost expert movie sure does go on for a
while without Luca Singh he really got
the soap opera coma treatment he's even
a twin Jesus they really need to unpack
these boxes and break them down so Lily
can get back to a life of less momma and
more healing jump-scare some scares are
the fart jokes of horror movies a cheap
reaction ploy that has no actual
substance and is so difficult to do
right it's probably not even worth the
effort
also what's Mama's intention here she
followed the girls to this house so
clearly she wants to be with her she
tried to kill Lucas but left Annabel
unharmed up to this point make up your
mind mama what's the ghost protocol for
how the deceased interact with
technology how did Lucas his brother
even access it why isn't he a real ghost
he's definitely got some wrongs to right
also whoever's manipulating this
computer picked up a copy of the
afterlife bestseller Java for mummies
I'll see you soon okay yeah but gene
just said that it was her day to see the
kids even though Annabelle told her to
leave that doesn't overrule a fucking
court decision right I'll take care of
him
those girls are the most important thing
in the world to me sounds like Nikolai
is American accent lasted about as long
as his brother did in this movie Hey
look it's a dark mass of something this
movie plays the laziest game of showing
the ghosts since the Paranormal Activity
movies which had probably less than 1%
of the budget this did also sure dr.
Dreyfuss is trying to figure out what
exactly he saw but he could have at
least given Annabelle a heads up that
she might want to get the fuck away from
the house and possibly the kids for a
few days also also why did mommy even
let dr. Dreyfuss sleep over 57 minutes
into this movie and mama has been all
spook and no scare November 3rd the 7th
session was more than revealing even if
I give them will be a pass for a
dictation narration can we just get to
the point already can mama at least try
to do something interesting either
visually or intellectually please mama
it is only the abilities to embrace a
different reality that makes science
expand beyond the limits of what we know
this dialogue is Dan Aykroyd approved
I shall crochet you what's up with this
Nickelodeon nudies tip for Lucas and
Annabelle's visions
why are Lucas and Annabel even having
visions at all what's going on in this
movie holy this movie went from team
EPOC jump-scares to whacked-out italian
giallo in a matter of minutes also
that's it
she killed to get her child back but
ended up ending both her and her child's
life and now wants to make up for it by
watching these girls I guess sometimes
the plot summary is the entire movie
exactly why is mommy fearest even
putting Jay Chazz in the backstory
splash zone in the first place I know
it's important to the plot that she
knows this information but wouldn't
Mama's jealousy trump her need to
randomly expose it oh thank god we've
got a whole 10 seconds between jump
scares in this scene how does Lily know
that this is the time that mama wants
them to come with her she's been coming
and going and ghosting up the joint
since they've gotten here so what makes
this time so different and once again
why didn't she just have the girls go
back with her immediately
scary mama noises sound more like the
afternoon shift at the local petting zoo
come on man auntie mushi Yeti repeated
this same trick for that slide projector
Pennywise scare scene in it at what
point does a signature become a cliche
what exactly was the doctor's plan here
he suspected there was a ghost here so
was he gonna ask her to pose for a quick
shoot with a regular ass camera so mama
is using this as a portal between this
house and a little cabin in the woods
right but why is it even that important
why does she need to go back to that
cabin anyway movie continues to
stubbornly refuse to explain any of this
awesome he discovered the place with the
thing from that other thing this
exciting revelation will lead to Lucas
going to that place and doing jack
until Annabelle shows up in the van also
when did he put that jacket on cuz when
he reached for that man he was just
sporting classic hospital gown
I need anomaly Enterprise for an ACOG
who calls information for a phone number
anymore you're holding a cell phone man
if you don't use your technology your
technology will end up using you so he's
good to leave the hospital by himself he
just woke up from a coma
isn't there a coma police that should
arrest this man how could you know that
story Vic Raschi showed me how in a
dream mama Krueger pg-13 horror movie
waste it's only f-bomb on a silly
voicemail message this is a very
touching scene and the work that both
actresses do in this fairly silly ghost
movie should be commended
but what sense does this make Victoria
knows a hug is gonna piss mama off and
probably get Annabelle killed great aunt
jeans back to try and catch some child
abuse on
film Jesus this movie has way too many
subplots I just want some hot mama
action and this would be the first time
I asked for that in a movie that's pg-13
if mama is so concerned with people
looking for him and maybe she should
leave a less distinct calling card and
someone tell me why mama looks and walks
like a praying mantis crossed with 1990s
video game CGI she was an actual human
woman
right and you thought you were having a
bad hair day damn I must let Hannibal
live for weeks in this place but Jean
doesn't last a full minute okay wait
mama can 15 possess people could someone
help me understand these powers and why
she's just unleashing this very useful
one just now how could you make it and
somehow I ended up on the exact part of
the road that you were driving down at
this exact moment but semantics let's
hog and maybe have a quickie in the van
before we go save the girls holy
Annabelle can you stop playing the
pronoun game and actually let Lucas know
what's going on he's been in a goddamn
coma Jane of course mama left jeans
hollowed out corpse in a standing
position so that we could get this
boring reveal leaning gene also how did
the girls even get there
did no one in between their house and
the cabin see two young girls just out
walking by themselves even if Jean was
walking with them she wasn't convincing
at all is an actual person oh I'm glad
Annabelle and Lucas can see what's going
on because I sure as I've completely
given up on understanding any other
rules or motivations for mom that she
actually want her baby she killing now
to protect Lily and Victoria or she
jealous she obviously can kill at will
so why is she waiting till now to start
why didn't she kill the two knuckleheads
who found the cabin that she walked
through the moth portal in jeans bonnie
with the girls to get here or did she
just drive them all the way here in
jeans car would she even know how to
drive a car and what going to end 20
sins to cover all this laziness finally
I wanna know the answer to and by being
incapacitated yet again for this final
scene Lucas firmly establishes his
status as the least essential character
in this movie also Lucas survives this
why didn't mama kill Annabelle all the
way she didn't afford the same luxury to
poor Jean
is this movie really trying to make us
feel good about a young child being moth
murdered by its demon ghost mother
that's dark
I immediately need to watch something a
little more hopeful to cleanse my palate
now where's my copy of the mist
good luck explaining to the caseworkers
how a ghost killed Angie then did a swan
dive with Lily that turned her into a
moth well we ended up with one out of
two kits so I guess it ain't all bad
want to hit up Burger King on the way
home
they called her mama did mama tell you
that story I think she could be taking
on the role of mama is this mom it's
mama Victoria Victoria talk about mama
you guys psyched about mama - right mama
didn't show you where is mama
[Music]
screw it let's beat bad mom's right into
the buckle that's gotta hurt Jean don't
gonna cause it I know nothing mommy's
not feeling well I guess we found out
his weakness bullets
by grabthar's hammer what are saving one
slap you're gonna love my nuts
can you show me mama um phrasing